the Joe Rogan experience I mean I think
all politicians hate reporters if they
if they don't there's probably something
wrong with them because you know the
press corps in most cases is really is
out to get them or at least is is
dangerous you know but with Trump and
Nixon it was it went to a whole new
level and went to a paranoid place and
you know but on the other hand I'm gonna
bore you with this but but the the
whining about being kicked out of the
White House and not being able to fly
with with Trump and and the sort of
separation between the president and the
press corps and the fact he doesn't show
up at the White House Correspondents
Dinner or like as a reporter my response
to that is so what we should be on the
outside you know like I don't shed a
tear about that I think it's very
strange the response in our business
that oh you know we're not we don't get
to be hanging around with the president
and and you know pal around behind the
rope line with them anymore like we
should be adversarial I think yeah well
if long as you are honest and accurate
yeah yeah I mean I mean not even
adversarial but not connected right
right yeah it's it's it's a kind of a
separation of church and state thing for
me like I had an experience when I could
when I covered the Obama campaign and I
liked Barack Obama as a candidate in
2008 I was really impressed by him but I
remember going into the plane the first
time going back into the press section
and I see that there's photos all over
the walls above the campaign plane and
apparently there's a tradition where
each of the reporters had like a little
sort of high school yearbook photo taken
with the candidate where you know they
got their arm around Obama and they're
posing and it was a tradition that kind
of put the the photo up on the wall
and I'm like you know this is not a good
look for for the press corps even if you
like the guy you got a you know at least
pretend to have a little bit of that the
mode is supposed to be there you know
what I mean what's the set is certainly
influential yes certainly gonna have
some sort of an influence on you yeah
yeah it's just a bad look like what
happens if you do a story about the guy
that's complimentary and it comes out
that you know you're you're you've put a
picture of yourself with your arm around
the guy you know what I mean you know
that it's just that's reporters are kind
of supposed to be these unpleasant you
know kind of grumpy people who instantly
deface the posters of you know powerful
people you know whenever they get a
chance and throw darts at pictures of
them and stuff like that like that's
that's who they kind of used to be and
you see there's people that are jockey
in the position to potentially run in
you know the next election obviously the
2018 elections but in 2020 for president
you seen people that are moving into
position you see these congressional
candidates that are showing promise like
what what is that when you're covering
this like what's that what's the feeling
of like the future from these races so
like what is it from the standpoint of
reporters like went but yeah well first
first of all like the the holy grail of
reporting is to latch on to a politician
before they become famous and before
they become president and follow them
all the way and that way you get to be
the insider who gets invited into the
Oval Office so it's it's like a it's a
big thing that a lot of reporters kind
of dream of is to is to latch on early
to somebody like Bill Clinton and become
the the sort of favorite reporter on
that beat that's why at the outset of
presidential elections you'll often see
a lot of jockeying with in newsrooms to
see who gets to cover which campaign
because people always want to pick the
winner because they think they're gonna
write get a book deal out of it at the
end and they're gonna end up having
their own show on MSNBC or whatever but
the
but yeah I mean the what's the feeling
right now like who are people coalescing
around is that what you're asking that -
yeah well I think there's the
expectation is that some of the same
people are going to be involved as
individual there's a lot of belief that
Bernie's going to run again but then
there's also Kamala Harris there's Cory
Booker
you know people believe that those folks
are going to run but oddly enough the
the press corps is less focused on that
than they would be normally I think
they're they're the only story that
matters to political reporters right now
is the Russia gay Trump thing and
they're following that and kind of
hoping that will be something that
happens instead of the 2020 election you
know that they're they're the big the
big sort of trial of Donald Trump is
what everybody's kind of waiting for
[Applause]